The optimist will say that this glass is half
full, while the pessimist proclaims it’s
half empty. Of course, others may suggest
that it’s completely FULL of the atoms that
make up water and air. Others still might
remind you that atoms are 99.99% empty space,
making the glass...mostly nothing! But in
all seriousness, can science explain your
emotional perspective and outlook on life?
It turns out, it may not be in your control.
Research has shown that those with two long
alleles on specific genes controlling serotonin
are more likely to focus on positive images
- like someone enjoying ice cream - compared
to those with a short allele on the same gene,
who are more likely to focus on negative images
- like someone being robbed. Variation in
the oxytocin receptor gene can also affect
your outlook; Individuals with two copies
of guanine are noted to be more optimistic
with higher self-esteem, while those with
copies of adenine were less positive. So it
seems that people may be genetically susceptible
to pessimism.
Interestingly, optimists are less likely to
be rehospitalized after coronary artery bypass
surgery, show higher academic achievements
and even better socioeconomic status. But
it’s not all good; they can overestimate
their abilities and underestimate risk. Pessimist,
on the other hand, have a more realistic view
of the world, are more cautious when planning
for the future and may even live longer. A
landmark study spanning 20 years found that
pessimists use a cautious approach to their
finances and health, avoiding risky behaviours
such as smoking and excessive drinking, ultimately
giving them the last laugh - literally - over optimists.
But, statistically, most of us are hardwired
to lean towards optimism. Known as the Optimism
Bias and found in around 80% of the population,
we tend to overestimate the probability of
positive events occurring in the future, while
grossly underestimating the probability of
negative ones. For example, even though the
divorce rate can be as high as 40%, most newlyweds
predict their probability of getting divorced
at...0%. Chances are, when you imagine your
future, it’s usually better than your current
situation. Furthermore, we often imagine ourselves
as being more intelligent, sociable and honest
than other people.
When we look at the brain, we actually see
the left half exhibits increased activity
when imagining positive events, whereas during
negative events the right half’s activity
increases, but to a much lesser degree. This
suggests that the brain chooses to ignore
and filter out negative information and focus
on positivity.
Our perspective is, whether you’re genetically
predisposed to see the glass as half empty
or half full - don’t waste water and just
drink the damn glass already!
This actually reminded us of another common
saying though, that “Giving is better than
receiving” - but is that scientifically
accurate? We answered that one over on AsapTHOUGHT
with a special GIVEAWAY which you can click
here or use the link in the description to
check out.
Special thanks to audible for supporting this
episode and giving you a free audiobook at
audible.com/asap. This week we wanted to recommend
the book ‘The Wright Brothers’ which is
the amazing story behind the brothers who
taught the world how to fly - while staying
optimistic through all the challenges they
faced! You can get a free copy at audible.com/asap
or any others of your choice from a massive
selection! We love them as they are great
when you’re on the go.
Don’t forget to ask your burning questions,
and subscribe for more weekly science videos.
:)